hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
tdm of busulfan for bone marrow
transplant patients
i am peter harsh for lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by waters corporation
to learn more visit www.waters.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
with that i'd like to now welcome our
speaker
esther lazzo esther is the lead medical
technologist at baptist hospital of
miami
hi thank you peter welcome to this
conference
pbm of the sulfan of bone marrow
transplantations
located in south florida baptist
hospital of miami is home
of the miami cancer institute the bone
marrow
transplant project and mci provides
sophisticated
and high quality cancer care to patients
in our region
and also to patients coming from other
countries
in our hospital physicians advanced
practices
providers pharmacists nursing
and laboratory staff work as a team
to monitor drugs like this sulfur in dmt
patients
two years ago the bmp project
and our chemistry lab decided to
implement
the therapeutic drug monitoring of the
surface house
for a better management of the bone
marrow transplant patients
two clinical and financial
considerations were taken
first the analysis of in plasma
requires a very short turnaround time
to adapt determine the optimum dose of
this of the sulfur
and to minimize the toxicity of this
drug
7 the reduction of a very expensive and
risky send out testing process
our management quickly approves the
acquisition
of the instruments and other equipment
needed to support the in-house project
today i will present to you the results
of the implementation and validation
process
of our busulfan testing method
biosurfan is a chemotherapeutic drug
used used as a component in the
myeloblades precondition
treatment before allergenic stem cell
transplantation
the surface prevents the immune system
from rejecting
new stem cells when they are
transplanted
the chemotherapeutic and cytotoxic
effects
of the sulfur are directly related with
the alkylation
of the dna
in clinical practice pdm is essential
for measuring
concentration of specific therapeutic
drugs
at designing intervals in the blood
pdm of disulfant is critical for
determining
proper dosage to completely ablate
the bone marrow and to prevent the toxic
effects
the sulfan concentrations below the
therapeutic range
put patients at risk of having a grass
failure
and the suffering levels above the
therapeutic range
increase the risk of transplant related
toxicity and mortality associated with
the occlusive
legal diseases convulsions and coma
this also has a narrow therapeutic
window
and its exposure and clearance very
significantly from patient to patient
so the therapeutic monitoring of the
sulfan is used
to ensure that patients are near to the
optimal
steady state concentration
for example in the intravenous qc dosing
protocol
the optimum value is 800 nanograms per
milliliter
we use busulfan in combination with
methylene and fluorobeam
as part of the preconditioning protocol
in patients
we will receive allergenic stem cell
transplant
the first dose of disorphan is given to
the patient
nine days before the bone marrow
transplant
in the intravenous qc dosing protocol
the recommending those of yousulfan
is giving every 6 hours for 3
consecutive days
the monitoring of yusuf is done only
after the first
dose of infusion and the dose is
adjusted
according to the area under the curve
for the test result
the goal of the musurfan drug level
monitoring is adjusting the dose
before the fifth infusion
the surface uses and q24 are the most
common dosing protocol
in the qsys protocol the first dose of
you suffer
is administered for two hours starting
at 6 a.m these blood samples are
collected at a specific time
first one after completion of the first
infusion
around aim additional specimens are
drawn
at 50 minutes 30 minutes
2 3 and 4 hours after
ending of infusion the specimens are
hand delivered to center processing in
the lab immediately after they are drawn
keeping them on eyes at all times
test and processing centrifuge blood
specimens
as soon as possible transfers the plasma
to plastic tubes
and places in refrigerator with a
maximum limit
of 45 minutes from the time of collation
of every sample
the lab performs and reports the
disulfant levels of
each plasma sample in nanogram per
milliliter
pharmacy calculates the pk parameters
area under the curve a steady state
concentration
and clearance using pk software
to recommend the visual fund those that
will be used during the rest of the
conditioning regimen
several factors are challenging during
the therapeutic drug monitoring of
musulfa
two of the most important are the
estimation of decay parameters
requires multiple blood samples to be
taken at a specific times
and degradation of this sulfur in plasma
at room temperature
potential errors during collection
transportation
and processing of the pka specimens can
affect
the accuracy for calculation of pk
parameters
some potential errors are sample line
contamination
wrong timing mislabeling delays
in proper storage and missing
information
in the second example the enormous
infusion sample
could be contaminated with disulfa and
therefore the first point is not fitted
in a linear manner with the other time
points
and affected the calculation of the area
under the curve
the turnaround time for the sulfur is
the time between a specimen collection
to final pkf report
to those adjustments the sulfam testing
requires a shorter arm time
so clinician can make a timely dosage
adjustment is needed
the turnaround time for the send out
protocol leads to important delays in
the adjustment of usual fan dosing
the plasma specimen are cheap overnight
to the reference lab
in normal conditions once the reference
lab receives the specimens
they run the testing and verbally called
the physician with each
result and those recommendations
do the longer tear run times adjustment
of dosing takes place before the seventh
dose of the conditioning regimen
a send out protocols requires precise
coordination to avoid transportation
issues loss of samples and others
on the other hand the busulfan
quantification in-house
is performed the same day of cold sample
collection
with less technical difficulties less
risks for the patient
and much better turnaround time the view
surface in-house testing allows
pharmacists and physicians to get
results faster
and to adjust the dosing before the
fifth series begins
the quantification of the sulfur in
plasma
means a sensitive and specific
analytical method many of the available
viewsusa methods
are complicated and time-consuming
requiring extensive sample preparation
like derivatization in gas
chromatography lcm sms
is the most used method in clinical labs
to analyze the surface concentration in
plasma with high accuracy
reproducibility and simple sample
preparation
del cms ms combines the separating power
of the liquid chromatography
and the high sensitivity and selective
mass
analysis capability of the typical
quad-core masses spectrometry
next we will describe the lcms ms
method for measuring of view surface
levels in plasma
implemented and validated and our in our
lab
now we have some cool question for you
does your lab perform tdm testing using
lcm sms
yes no we probably do in the future
no other methods are used
for example in unisa
it is your lab considering to implement
the surface
using lcm sms
yes no no applicable
the quantification of these sulfide
through lc mass expect
requires some conditions and materials
laboratories must consider selecting an
optimized lc column to develop
a good chromatography method
selecting lc mobile phases compatible
with the massive spec and is possible
with other methods implemented in the
lab
using the identification criteria for
mass spec
in compliance with clear and cap
recommendations
use an isotope label of the sulfur as
internal standard to control variation
in recovery
matrix effects and ionization
a sample preparation procedure according
to the volume of samples
the matrix effects and analyze recovery
results
obtained during the validation
commercial calibrators are not available
we use calibrators
preparing house with nine levels of
concentration
commercial quality controls are not
available for resources neither
quality control materials are preparing
in the lab or
custom-made but specialized
companies lastly proficient in testing
programs for tbn of the
system using lcms spec instrumentations
are not available
from cap agc and other organizations
we choose a quick and simple protein
precipitation procedure
which removes a part of the phospholipid
content present
in plasma samples that minimize the
analyzed recovery
usually is extracted for 15 microliters
of plasma
mixed with the is standard spike in
methanol
after simplification 50 microliters of
supernatant is diluted with 500
microliters of water
to minimize the matrix effects
then the diluted supernatant is injected
in
on the uplc mass spec for analysis
the total extraction time of one batch
that includes calibrators quality
controls
at cis patient samples is around 15
minutes
the chromatography separation of this
surface and the internal standard is
obtained
within 2.5 minutes using a water's
equity uplc
column and a mobile phase composed of
ammonia acetate
forming acid and and water and water
or methanol for a total run time of
three minutes
the sulfur and internal standard are
detected in a water civilian mass spec
using positive ionization and they are
quantifying
using a multiple reaction monitoring
method
we selected two ion transitions
characteristic
for the sulfur and one ion transition
for the
internal standard
quantification of the sulfur is
performed
by plotting the response ratios of the
calibrators
against the known concentration of each
calibrator
the calibration includes a regression
analysis to verify
linearity once a viewsocian calibration
curve
is accepted quality control samples are
in range
and individual samples are inspected for
data
integration the patient samples can be
tested
currently most of the mass specs methods
are laboratory development tests or ldt
which requires an extensive technical
and analytical edge expertise prior
clinical implementation
in our lab validated the visual methods
according to the requirements of cia and
cap was part of
our work during this process
the lab must establish the acceptance
criteria for each component
of the method validation
combining the chromatographic conditions
and the mass effect
method the mususa and internal standard
can be separated from
other matrix components we use the
identification criteria in compliance
with clean
cap recommendations about compound
identification
using ion ratios and retention time
the sulfur and musuzan d8 are separated
by their masses
different the detection is done using
two
ion ratios for resultant one one ions
and one called ions
and one ion ratio for the internal
standard
the lower limit of quantification is 20
nanograms per milliliter
and it was defining in our lab as the
lowest concentration where the
coefficient
of variation is less than 10 percent
an accuracy or bias less than 15 percent
the method is linear over the clinical
concentration range
of 20 to five thousand nanogram per
milliliter
with an excellent accuracy and precision
coefficient of variation are less than
five percent for
all calibrators standards with an
excellent correlation
coefficient
matrix effects and recovery experiments
were
evaluated at three levels of busulfan
concentration
in plasma the recovery of the
fulfillment of
the surgeon was more than 98 percent
we can conclude that the protein
precipitation is very efficient for the
surface quantification
we also obtain no significant
differences
in the response between the musulfan and
internal standard spike
into plasma or the source of an internal
stand
spike into the movie phase this is
mainly possible
because we use the iterated internal
standard
that compensates the variation during
the sample preparation
and the mass spec analysis
make this effects on an analyte and
ionization can be
involved directions suppression and
enhancement cap requires
the analysis of at least 10 patient
plasma samples during the matrix effect
evaluation in our assessment
all suppression enhancement results were
less than 10 percent
meaning the matrix effect does not
affect the sa
accuracy
using the muscling software we create a
graph
for routine monitoring of the area of
the internal standard
uncharacteristic deviation of the
internal standard
area of the calibrator qc or patient
samples
can indicate an error in sample
processing
or signal interferences caused by matrix
companies
the use of a stable deuterated internal
standard helps control variability in a
quantitative essay
carry over was not accepted in our
validation process
we recommend a carryover assessment of
every analytical batch
by processing a blank quality control
sample
immediately following the high
calibrator
no evidence of analyze must be in the
blank sample
we did not deter interference with any
several codominant medication spike at
height concentration
the precision was evaluated using three
control samples
at different concentrations in this
table
you can see that the average coefficient
of variation within ron
and between run is under three percent
indicating an excellent reproducibility
an accurate quantification of busulfan
concentration
is the key for effective drug monitoring
and maximization of
therapeutics effects the accuracy
was evaluated comparing 124 samples
including patient samples and
proficiency testing specimens
with a validated mass expect method
the mean percentage of bias between the
disorder and concentration
measure with our method and measured by
the reference method
was four point four things percent
this is an excellent result considering
that the maximum acceptable bias for
a test performance is ten percent
the bias as a and a correlation
coefficient
of 0.99 confirm the
excellent accuracy of our method
the stability validation studies
confirmed that this surface unstable in
plasma
and is stable up to six months with
when it is frozen the instability of
the surface plasma is taking into
account in the procedures
for collecting processing storing
storing samples transporting samples
preparing calibrators and quality
control
materials to obtain reliable analytical
data
the precision of the method of using sa
is verified with the internal quality
control
in this slide we show you the qc charts
for three levels of yusuf and qc plasma
sample
the percentage of bias against the
target values
for each qc levels is less than five
percent
a very good precision compared with the
clear acceptance limits
of 15 percent three levels of quality
contours are enqueued
included in every batch of samples to
determine a system's performance
proficiency testing program from visual
using mass expect instrumentation
are not commercially available we and
others participate in the viewsource and
cross verification program
organized by seattle pke laboratory
other labs send blind samples to a
reference lab that use
same methodology to compare results
seattle prepares a report including the
analysis of results of
every participant in lab compared with
the theoretical
values assigned for each sample
here you see how an in a set musulfind
quantification method affects the
calculation of the dose adjustment
the lab 1 did not pass the criteria of a
sentence of the cross verification
assessment
the dos adjustment suggested for the lab
1
differs by up to 50 from the one
proposed by the reference
lab
this is the analysis we did for a
specific round
of theater cross-verification exercise
where the results are compared with the
fear mean
using the mass spec methodology
the percentage of biopain is less than
five percent
in every proficiency testing sample
the implementation in-house of an
efficient and cost-effective method
for the sulfur provides economic
and quality care improvement for bmc
patients
the busulfan testing in our last
provides a shorter turnaround time
reduced costs and eliminates the
risky send out testing process helping
pharmacists and bone marrow transplant
groups
to get results in a faster and precise
manner to adjust these surface
levels before they fix those
the results we have presented to you
today led us to conclude that we have
developed
and validated a quick sensitive
accurate and reproducible method for the
quantification of disulfide in human
plasma
using liquid chromatography tandem must
expect
technology our methodologies
is reliable for using therapeutic
monitoring of the
sulfur in plasma samples of the empty
patients
this has been a thin effort from the lab
staff to the physicians
pharmacies and nursing to the patients
and we work as a team at miami hospital
and baptist hospital of miami thank you
very much for your attention
would you like to speak to words
especially and how to can
help you to optimize the tdm
analysis method
thank you esther for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the
far left of your screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for
well let's start with our first question
what
data is used to monitor ensure assay
control
you showed that the absolute area counts
are monitored for the internal standard
but what about relative retention time
iron ratios or
other parameters
we use a period we use ion radius
characteristics for the sulfide one ion
transition as a quantifier
and one ion transition as a qualifier
and also we select one ion transition
monitoring for the internal standard
with a transition ratio analysis
tolerance
within 30 percent in addition the
retention time
is used in the analyte identification we
said tolerance within
one percent
okay thanks esther for that
related to it what happens when the
internal standard area is below
their threshold values or falls outside
of the
uh confidence interval
yes an aberrant deviation with
internal standard area
internal standard area of standards pc
or
other samples could be caused by an
error during the sample processing for
example
where you are the tech is pipetting the
internal standard solution
a signal interferences in the sample
patient sample
that maybe could be another factor
and maybe due for the unusual components
present
in the matrix or in this case the plasma
to be also affected for instrument
malfunctions
uh air source errors something like that
samples no meeting the acceptance
criteria
in uh in our say is a
the deviation of between within 25
percent must be
repeated and furthest investigated
okay great uh looks like we have
time for one more question uh has your
lab looked at dry blood spots
as an alternative sampling technique for
therapeutic drug monitoring requirements
we have not evaluated the the clinic
application of blood spot
using dbs to quantify the sulfur
concentration
dbs is particularly used useful
bases in some publication in centers
using external laboratories to
to processing the sulfur or for example
in pediatrics patient
where collate collection is a collection
is super
the sample is uh to be difficult
okay thank you for that well
thank you esther do you have any final
comments for
our audience
well we are very happy to be
here and share our validation results
with all the audience and
okay thank you so much for your
attention
any questions please send me to by
my email or to the honda email that is
the chemistry lab managers
or in baptist hospital
okay thank you again esther for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor waters corporation for
underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided on the
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert uh you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who have
missed today's live event until then
goodbye